this is the nikola one a semi truck
designed to run
on electricity and hydrogen not diesel
it was unveiled to the world in december
2016
and at the time investors seemed
confident that it was a first step
towards a hydrogen fuel-powered future
it's my pleasure to introduce
the nikola one to the world
after going public in june nicolas
market cap briefly surpassed ford
fueled by big promises made by founder
trevor milton and a frenzy of investor
excitement
in the electric vehicle industry but
more recently the eevee startup has been
mired in controversy
nikola shares are tumbling after a short
seller called the company quote an
intricate fraud built on dozens of lies
just months after the company's shares
hit all-time highs
its stock has lost almost 80 percent of
its value
this is the cautionary story of nikola
the wall street darling that now faces
federal investigations
and an uncertain future
we've essentially doubled the freight
efficiency of our freight and the first
people in the world
ever do that on a on a diesel in the
last long time
in december 2016 when nikola unveiled
the prototype
founder trevor milton claimed the truck
was fully functioning and that it had
generated 2.3 billion dollars in
pre-sales in its first month
investment from the auto industry began
to flow in
investors are interested in electric
cars because it's the future of the
industry global warming
uh emissions targets and government
regulation are all kind of pushing in
that direction
over the following year nikola quietly
gained attention as trevor milton spoke
at events
and sold his vision to investors around
the world here he is in oslo norway
i know right now i can provide europe
and norway a truck that is 30 percent
less than a diesel
and is a 100 zero emission the company's
ceo
not only promised a zero-emission
hydrogen and electric truck
but the fuel and cross-country
infrastructure of power stations
to support it three months later the
company released a video of its
semi-truck
it represented it as in motion leaving
the viewer to interpret it as propelling
itself
in just a few days later nicola
announced plans for a 1 million square
foot
arizona manufacturing facility that
would provide 2 000 jobs
so today i am proud to announce
that nikola motor company is coming to
arizona
fast forward to april 2019 nikola had
another big announcement
introducing the most advanced semi truck
the world
has ever seen the first hydrogen
production
class a truck that can beat a diesel in
every category
ladies and gentlemen the nikola 2.
well the company revealed the nikola ii
they had not yet finished or sold
any of the nikola ones the company says
that it was a successful proof of
concept
but they never appeared to have finished
or
built or sold any of them piccolo was
really selling investors
on an idea and a vision of the future a
zero emission
you know transportation heavy world that
they
not only made trucks for but made and
sold fuel for
and nikola seemed committed to that
vision in november the company completed
what it claimed was the first ever zero
emission beer delivery
in partnership with anheuser-busch which
had previously put in an
order for 800 hydrogen electric semi
trucks
and after the demonstration public
enthusiasm for the company continued to
grow
when nikola went public on june 4th 2020
it shot out of the door
just days later milton tweeted that
orders would soon open for the
all-electric badger pickup truck
the next day the company's stock doubled
shares of
electric truck maker nicola are rallying
a day later nikola's market value
briefly surpassed ford
and the successes didn't stop two months
later
nikola released an earnings report that
it had lost 86 million dollars in a
quarter
but the eevee startup quickly bagged
another order this time for 2500 trucks
from garbage giant republic services
still
investor enthusiasm continued to grow
and on september 8th
nikola announced a major new partnership
with auto heavyweight
general motors nicola badger will be
engineered and manufactured by gm
gm getting an 11 ownership stake in
nikola
trevor milton was really kind of a
consummate showman
um he held these big events where he had
these big reveals of trucks
that may or may not have really
functioned
he was capable at getting other
companies to invest in his vision
and and lend their credibility to nicola
sit back and watch what happens over the
next five years you're going to see
nikola become one of the most valuable
brands in the world
just four years after unveiling its
first truck prototype nikola was worth
billions of dollars
and yet it still hadn't sold a single
product and as the world watched over
the following weeks
its story began to unravel on september
10th
short seller hindenburg research
released a report that sent nicholas
stock
plummeting they say they the company has
made false statements
it has rigged its truck reveals and it's
had misleading demonstrations
one of the accusations was about that
third-party video on nikola's youtube
channel
of the nicola one prototype in motion
the short seller
alleged that to shoot this video nikola
had simply pulled the truck
up a somewhat of a small hill and let it
roll down
nikola responded as a company saying
that you know they never represented the
truck as driving under its own power
but i think a lot of commenters and
and you know observers felt that it was
kind of
a tacit admission that the short seller
had kind of been right
i think there's definitely the threat of
class-action lawsuits and some law firms
are recruiting plaintiffs
federal prosecutors are looking for
answers as well
on september 15th the wall street
journal reported that the department of
justice and the sec
were investigating claims that nikola
had misled investors
many of these claims focused on trevor
milton nicolas frontman
and just a week later the founder and
executive chairman
resigned from the company's board
following the news shares of the eevee
startup
plunged even further just days later
reports surfaced that nicholas talks
with partners to build hydrogen stations
had stalled
in the few weeks after the report came
out on september 10th nicola
lost about 45 percent of its market cap
uh the partnership that it had announced
on september
8th with general motors uh was supposed
to close at the end of september and has
not yet closed it's started to affect
nikola's ability to
attract and retain partners but at this
key moment nikola doubled down
the company reiterated its business plan
and some milestones that it expects to
hit
over the next few years um and really
kind of
reasserted uh that that it's focused
right now on
execution of its business plan in a
post-trevor milton era
following this news the truck maker's
stock price began to slightly recover
and its new leadership seemed confident
the company's been public for what four
months
um so you know we're comfortable with
the diligence we did
a lot of analysts have actually
reiterated that they do believe in
nicola
um and that they ultimately see that the
the moving on from trevor milton as a
good thing
for the company in the long run um but a
lot of those analysts too have written
about you know nicolas kind of need to
reestablish credibility
even though customers have yet to flock
to electric vehicles
big auto companies and investors are
betting they will soon
fueling an interest in showy startups
like nikola the fact that the markets
can both be
so quickly taken with a company like
nikola and then
quickly kind of disenchanted with that
company
in a matter of months is kind of a
cautionary tale of some of the
enthusiasm around
electric vehicle startups and and kind
of
betting betting it all in the future
with new leadership
certain major partnerships still in
talks and multiple federal
investigations underway
nikola's future remains in the balance